起きてー！
おいおいおい  起きて起きて
手を繋いで 寄り添って
はい完成！
こんにちは   はじめしゃちょーです
Twitter やってると ちょっと
あの フォロワーさんの方から
すごい情報が入ってきました！
てか 普通にTwitter でも
話題になってたんですけども
あると思うんですよ
あのー 例えば
ガリガリ君とか
チョコボールとか
当たり付きのお菓子って
あると思うんですけど
あれって思ったより当たんないですよね
僕も当たったことが人生この方
たぶん30回くらいしか
結構  当たってますね
たまに当たるんですけども
その 当たりとはずれ付きのお菓子が
あるんですけども
それの あの確実に当たりが当たる方法が
あるみたいです
それがTwitter で話題になってたんですけども
えっと 4つありまして
1つは えっと
10円ガム
チョコバットの当たり
あと チョコボールの当たり
よっちゃんイカの当たりの
当て方があるみたいです
それでは「はじめんはじめん！」
「これが本当かどうか調べてください」
「 よろしくお願いします」
という説があったので
調べていきます！
これ 本当だったら大変ですよ
各地でチョコバット よっちゃんイカ
チョコボールの奪い合いが起き
日本は大混乱
政府は2018年2月から起きたこの大反乱を
と名付けた
社会の授業で載るかもしれません
気を付けてください
では 早速 見ていきましょう
まずは チョコバットから見ていきます
これ ほんとだったら超お得な感じです
えー チョコバットなんですけども
どこだ？どこだ？
これ ちょっとなんか
Twitter に載ってるやつと
違うチョコバットだぞ
これ違うぞ！なんか！
パッケージ外側の「くじ付き」
左上にギザギザの頂点が
やや丸みを帯びているのが
ホームランバージョン
ええ？
送られてきた画像にあるチョコバットは
なんかこのバットもってる少年の
やつなんですけど
僕 買ったのもうゴリゴリ
外野手がボールをベースに返してる
絵なんですけど
え！じゃあ無理じゃん！
え 待って   無理じゃん無理じゃん
いや 逆にこれ俺  自分で発見すれば
いいんじゃないかな？
ちょっとこの
外野手バージョンのチョコバットの
当たりくじを調べましょう
パッケージにその当たりくじって
分かる何かがあるんだったら
それを逆に俺が
探せばいいってことでしょ？
あー はずれ ×1
はずれ ×2
はじゅれ ×3
はずれ ×4
はずれ ×5   はずれ ×6
はずれ ×7
はずれ ×8   はずれ ×9
はずれ ×10   はずれ ×11
はずれ ×12   はずれ ×13
はずれ！まさかもうサーチ済みかこれ
サーチ済みなんか？
はずれ ×15   はずれ ×16   はずれ ×17
はずれ ×18   はずれ ×19   はずれ ×20
はずれ ×21   はずれ ×22
ｵｲ!   ｳｪｲ!   ｱｰ!   ｴｰ!
ｳｫｰ!   ｳｪｰ!   ｳｪｰ!   ﾜｰ!   ｱｰ!   ｳｰ!
おいおいおいおいおい
やばい！ 34本 買って
1本しかなかったくせに
ホームランが出たら一番いいんですけども
ストライクしか出ませんでした
えぐい…
ただこれによってこの
当たりとはずれが今 出たんで
パッケージになにかしらの違いが
ないかちょっと見ていきましょう
こっちが当たり  こっちがはずれです
開け方が汚すぎて申し訳ないんですけど
たぶん細かいところなんですよね
あのTwitter に載ってたのも
すごい細かかったんで
んーーー
分かんねえなあ
指の本数も一緒でしょ？
二重  眉毛の角度も一緒
いやー だめだな
まったく一緒です 無理！
そもそも もう当たりすらも
引けませんでしたっていう感じでした
ちっ！うめえな
次はこちら よっちゃんイカです
よっちゃんイカのヒントは
賞味期限、賞味期限の字が
薄かったらハズレ
濃かったら当たりみたいです
なるほどな、あーあるあるある
待てよ？
今 見たんですけど どこにも
なんか当たり付きの要素がないんですよね
当たり付きよっちゃんイカの当たりって
どうなってるんだろ
あっ！まさか！
うめえ
多分BIG カットよっちゃんイカには
当たりっていう概念がないっすね
BIG じゃない方の
普通のよっちゃんイカにしか
多分ないみたいです
ふざけんじゃねえぞ
ただの普通によっちゃんイカ
買っただけになっちゃった
【悲しげなBGM】
てことはもうコンビニに
普通のよっちゃんイカ売ってなかったから
もうそもそも俺はこれは
無理だったことだったんだよ ちっ！
では最後 チョコボールいきます！
やばい このままだとなにも得られない
せめて当たりだけでも当てたい！
えーと チョコボールはですね
わー これはまた難しいっすね
キョロちゃんがいると思うんですけども
キョロちゃんのくちばしが
キレイだったら当たり
で なんか色がはみ出たりしていたら
はずれみたいです
なるほど  ちょっと1回
並べてみましょうか
ほーほー なるほど なるほど
なるほど なるほど
いや どれもキレイなんだけど
そうだ めっちゃ細かいんだろ
もっと 近くで見ないと分かんない
くちばしの色がなんか
赤い部分にはみ出てたら
はずれなんで
はみ出てなかったら当たりなんですけど
全部はみ出てない…
ってことは
それか もうパッケージが更新されて
新しくなっちゃってそういうなんか
当たりは分かりやすいみたいなのが
なくなってる可能性もあります
ぱっと見 全部 同じなんですよ
はみ出てるやつ自体がまず
いないんすよね 多分
ほら 全員くちばしが
キレイな色になってるんで
多分パッケージが
更新されてますね これは
てことは もう また
全部 開けていきます
まず当たりを見つけよう
金のエンゼルが入ってない限りは
なにも始まんないんで
はずれ ×1
はずれ ×2
はずれ ×3
はずれ ×4
あー！ おい！
おいおい
え！ おい！
え  待って
このままだと   俺は
一体…
なにやってんだろ…
【ED】